I've been with wnet for 10 years we are
a public broadcaster we operate channel
13 and channel 21 here in New York where
the producer presenter of some of the
key PBS programs including nature great
performances American masters Charlie
Rose the news our most trusted video
content available and we have a very
strong partnership with educators
particularly K through 12 I've been
counseling producers and educators on
rights I've produced films myself and so
I understand the whole rights process
from the Edit room perspective and the
headaches of the brainstorms and calling
up the lawyers and being the lawyer so I
want to give a little bit of perspective
from the trenches and put it in the
context of what's going on in the
commercial world because the whole
notion of free rights and fair use and
Creative Commons is a little port in a
big storm that's going on and it's a
very important port I just want to cover
a couple of basics I'm trying to do this
quickly so we have a lot of time first
of all for Eric to talk about the second
part of his presentation which is
critical and for there to be time for
discussion traditionally the way we
negotiate rights is with we negotiate
them in terms of manner and media
territory and term and remember that
Trinity because it isn't going to be
here for much longer we also negotiate
in terms of exclusivity and exclusivity
is critical to any rights package today
but that's also going to change the
bottom line is negotiations for rights
are about money trying to give up as few
rights as possible for as much money as
you can get or the other way around
paying as little for as much as you can
get that's always the tension that's
what's going on in most of the world the
market and the prices for these rights
are driven on how we monetize viewership
of video
content and that happens in two ways
either a pay to view model like a movie
theater or a DVD sale or rental or
freeview supported by ads or sponsorship
like television the web even public
television and technology is changing
viewership radically and quickly and
more so now than ever before the
internet is now a high-end video portal
computers are now video receivers and
playback devices ipods are offering a
whole new format this change in
viewership is changing where we monetize
viewership and i want to put up you've
got it this one slide which illustrates
the tipping point that's going on in our
industry look at where the ad dollars
are spent today compared to viewership
this is a slide that that shows the the
green lines are the money spent the red
lines represent viewership and if you
look at the top line you're going to see
how out of whack our ad spending is
print is spending six times its share or
sixty percent of its money sorry six
times its share compared to the
viewership of print so you've got six
percent of the population reading and
thirty percent of the money is going
into reading is going into advertising
on printed material the internet is the
is is half we're spending half our money
advertising on the internet but double
the amount of time this is all going to
rationalise in the next 18 months and
you're going to see that this spends and
the viewership are going to be equal
through each category of media and the
reason this is so critical is what's
happening in the commercial world is
going to change how we think about
rights and how we define them with the
internet and TV convergence linear and
on-demand programming are all going to
come to your house through one box if
they're not already doing that your one
click of a mouse or remote control away
from whatever you want whether it's pay
pay to view it or adds up
or did free viewing and with these new
models we're going to have very
interesting new deals in terms of how we
distribute content for money they're
going to be combinations paid of view
and ad-supported there's going to be
it's all going to be happening in your
box seamlessly but the deals behind the
scenes are going to be right now very
complicated because we're figuring them
out and no one's quite sure how they're
going to make money the record industry
has been wrestling with this for five
years and I see all the Apple computers
in the room and that's the guy who's
figured out a big piece of it it's
really stunning how many little apples
i'm looking at 11 sony 25 apples and
Adele so remember the Trinity manner and
media territory term exclusivity or all
in terms of exclusivity with these new
formats well when we when we'd add a new
technology the Trinity would just add
that format to manor media for example
DVD came along and you just had manor
media TV internet now DVD the
Territorian term were just some logical
extension of what should a DVD life in
the marketplace bait today I'm not sure
that manner and media matter anymore TV
DVD cable VOD internet it's all coming
in your house in through one screen so
we don't need that definition the
distinctions are again differences
without a real distinction territory
well the web doesn't really tolerate
borders and while there are geo filters
out there and some companies are using
them and some of us are getting asked to
use them in our licenses they're really
not practical for popular culture
content or broadly distributed content
and I think in the end of the day
they're going to go away I don't think
the marketplace is going to tolerate
them so I think territory is over time
going to disappear as a relevant part of
the
trinity and term well once it's on the
internet there's no pulling it back so i
think term is really going to become
irrelevant and i think we're going to
think about defining or describing
rights instead of using that that
trinity of descriptors we're going to
think of end users we're going to think
of are they at home are they in a
classroom are they looking at it on
their little ipod or wristwatch or they
in a theater and how are they paying for
it are they paying to view it or is it
ad supported so let's look at how this
would impact a rights definition for
home video typically home videos defined
as DVD sale or rental well now it's
going to be home use and it's going to
mean the purchase or rental for viewing
at your home who cares how it got there
TV is now going to encompass broadcast
cable satellite internet again who cares
how it got into your home it's an
ad-supported stream of linear
programming and that's going to be the
definition and it's going to be about
how do the rights holders get their
money and what about exclusivity we
always describe our Trinity in terms of
I've got these exclusive rights I'm not
sure that exclusivity is going to be
relevant the same way it has been in the
past I'm on the fence about this but if
you look at things like YouTube in my
space and all the new sites that the
public flocks do to look at video we all
want our content there and the fastest
way to get it there is to let the public
put it there and post it just like the
fastest way in the educational market
for people to use an exploit video is to
let the educators teachers and the
students just start using it that's how
it's going to get there that's the
quickest way we're not even going to
know as a producer or distributor which
the best site is the hottest site just
you know is suddenly there today gone
tomorrow it all moves someplace else and
I want my content there but I want to
make money on Mike
10 and that's what we're wrestling with
how am I going to make money if my
contents post it all over the place
there's always going to be a place for
exclusivity if you look at feature films
there's always going to be this
windowing where certain content is going
to be there'll be a premium in the
marketplace but again I think the the
notion that non-exclusive was sort of an
odd term of art before and something
that lawyers and business affairs folks
were uncomfortable with I don't think
that's going to happen anymore so I
think it's in play what does this all
mean for best practices I think it's a
little early to start saying we know
what the best practices are going to be
but I think the bottom line is we need
to tag and track our content so that we
can collect money and that ties right
into what's going on in the education
market today we're looking at our
archives and we're looking at how we can
use video clips in the classroom and how
people can swap these things and expand
on them and what we need to have is a
way to you've got to have an archive
you've got to manage your archive and
you've got to deal with the insane cost
of building and managing that archive
and that's the big challenge for public
television in the big challenge for
educational institutions the commercial
entities haven't figured out how to do
it either there's no perfect system
there's I think five hot software
products out there now none of them are
terrific they all have pros and cons
they're very expensive so I think we
need to think about how we're going to
manage our archive and I think that's a
place where public broadcasting and the
education market can really collaborate
where we're working right now nyu wgbh
PBS in the library of congress on the
American archive what you think you guys
heard about yesterday that's a great
example account collaboration the other
thing we need is we need some changes in
the law and I think we can collaborate
on that as well if you look at what the
copyright law does for educators and
public broadcaster's it gives us free
music for Public Broadcasting well
broadcasting is going to go with the
Trinity it's not it doesn't matter how
it gets in your home anymore yet
it's only free if it's broadcast so
we're going to rethink what public
broadcasting means in the Copyright Act
it also gives schools and I love this
one seven days to record what I
broadcast on public television and then
replay it in the classroom as if you're
going to be doing in your curriculum
what I've done on American masters
Wednesday night Thursday morning a
teacher is going to be in there talking
about Ella Fitzgerald because well once
put you know in the US revolution on
hold and let's talk about Ella
Fitzgerald it doesn't work it never
worked and we need to change that
classroom use of public television media
and that's that's such a simple fix I
think we can Lobby together to make that
happen there are some other things we
should be thinking about in terms of
changing the Copyright Act to support
the things that Eric's group is doing
and the other things that universities
and public broadcasters are doing and I
think that the critical thing I'm just
looking at some of the other comments I
had I wanted to really want time for us
to talk about these things I think the
critical thing as we look at all this is
to remember that the big mover in the
market is always going to be money and
whatever we do is going to have to look
at what are the commercial models and
how can we take advantage of those
models and how can we find a place among
those models where no one feels like
we're ripping them off but instead
bringing our social value into the
education market in a public
broadcasting out to the public